他们把我养到14岁，
他们计精心的计划着给我喂了多少草料，
给我喂了多少粮食，
精心的算着投资回报率，
他们不能称之为我的养父养母，
他们只是我的地主，
我在他们家只是一个长工，
那长工他是有工资的长工，
他还完了地主家的债，
还完了这些草料，
还完了这些粮食，
他是可以解除这个关系的。
我想问一下，
我要不要回去，
回去之后应该怎么跟他们相处，
我以后要不要继续跟他们保持联系，
要不要来往？
我是养女，
一开始是被三大养一岁，
后来一岁之后给了我找父母一样，
我14岁当天出来打工的，
打工的时候呢，
身份证跟银行卡都在养父母手里，
一个礼拜100块钱，
零花钱花多了就挨骂，
只能花少就好，
留一点的给到他们。
我今年28岁，
前段时间我生病了，
因为我牙齿出了很大问题，
就只能吃流食。
那一个月我瘦了，
肋骨头看拎清二楚，
原本有110的体重，
瘦到了90多斤。
后来问家里要钱，
想看牙齿，
当年说没有钱，
他说你打工打了这么多年，
给的钱是应该给我们的，
家里没有责任跟义务给你存钱，
我就没钱买药。
旁边饭店大姐看到我哭，
给了我50块钱，
让我去买药。
上年前父亲养父去世了，
是每个月给家里2000~2500的人每年。
过年回家再给家里1万块钱的人，
家里小到牙膏牙刷卫生纸都是我买，
大到洗衣都是我买。
养父去世前一个月，
我给家里给了1万块钱，
后来养父走的时候，
我刚好出来工作，
第三天嘛，
我没有钱，
川是在威胁老板的意思嘛，
给老板下跪，
我让他给我钱，
我说我回杨副肘，
你必须要给我调分配次工资，
我就把身份证压在了老板那里，
我回家了，
前后给了家里一万五，
因为办葬里嘛，
但是我发现后来听车的的时候，
大姐是一分钱都没给家里，
二姐呢，
是给了2000，
然姆说杨副总还是需要钱，
要问我要钱，
但我身上已经有一分钱了，
而且我还欠一个月工资，
欠老板的工资。
后来我出来工作之后，
情况也不是特别好，
老板也知道我身在体弱，
多病，
后来各种各样的理由把我辞退了，
我现在找了别的工作，
我生病之后问家里要钱，
家里没给，
但我二姐过的嫁的比较好，
她的婆家可以买房买车那种条件哦，
是比较好的。
二姐她们家买了个车，
车上呢就挂那种小玩具嘛，
200块钱一个小玩具，
我说你车上可以挂那种小玩具，
能能给我点薪，
一百两百都行，
不给我。
再后来因为我姐的孩子嘛，
我姐还是跟我相差8岁，
我只要过年回家，
我带她买东西，
我记得有一次就为什么别人家小朋友可以吃好的，
玩好了吃肯德基，
我没有，
后来我一听，
我三天时间带她去我们市里花了5000块。
给他各种买各种买，
后来我出了这个事情以后，
家里人都不跟我联系了，
微信也把我拉黑了，
连这个小孩儿就把我微信删了，
所以有人关心我一句话，
哪怕是一个关心都行，
哪怕你给我50块钱，
100块钱也是个帮助，
后来就彻底不联系了，
我们现在有12年时间没联系了，
没有人跟我，
后来我尝试跟老家人，
因为老家人事在跟我同龄嘛，
我就问他们，
他说你今年不回来过年嘛，
我说我没说不回去，
他说你养我说你不回来过年，
你还不想回来，
是你的问题，
就是这个意思。
堂哥想让我回去，
我不再想回去，
一个是钱，
我现在快30岁了，
我还掉看病的债务，
我现在身上的钱只有几千块钱，
另一个是我回去了，
我应该把这些所有事情讲给车里人听，
因为现在村里人都以为他是大善人，
把我养了14岁，
我出去打工，
给钱给了我28，
给到26，
我给了十十三年的钱。
但是有一点是什么呢？
我给家里买的冰箱，
各种各样的东西吧，
他从来不跟任何人讲，
不跟任何人提别扔了，
他都不说。
我跟杨总打电话，
他去超市买东西，
他说没有钱，
我当即找了他3000块钱，
他不跟陶人说是我转的。
后来我一个婶婶去家里玩，
说你这个冰箱很好，
他说谁买的，
他说自己买的，
他也不说是我买的。
后来我听了，
我就很大声的说，
我说是我买的，
婶行，
是我买给家里面的，
我买了两台，
一台买给了家，
一台买给了姐姐家里，
二姐只要给家里。
买一壶油，
哪怕55块钱金龙鱼油，
他就到处说我现在的内心情况，
我不太想回去，
我是说真的，
但是堂哥说，
如果你不回的话，
你过两年回，
到时候太多那种是是非非了。
姑娘，
如果我是你的话，
第一我不可能再回去了，
第二，
我管他什么这堂哥那姐姐，
这个亲戚，
我不需要向任何人去证明我对这个家庭有贡献，
为什么不需要向任何人去证明呢？
因为他们根本就不能称之为我的养母，
某种程度上，
他们是我的地主，
我只是他们豢养的一个长工，
他们把我养到14岁，
他们既精心的计划着给我喂了多少草料，
给我喂了多少粮食，
精心的算着投资回报率，
他们不能称之为我的养父养母，
他们只是我的地主，
我在他们家只是一个长工，
那长工他是有工资的长工，
他还完了地主家的债，
还完了这些草料，
还完了这些粮食，
他是可以解除这个关系的。
你不要把你身边的那些什么这堂哥，
那表姐，
这姐姐们，
他们不是我的亲人，
他们都是我的地主，
我现在我30岁了，
我能拿着我自己的身份证，
我在哪里，
我的家就在哪里，
哪里有关心我的人，
哪里才有我的家，
哪里有爱我的人，
你。
当那些不爱你的人去证明你对他们有多好这件事情你想想你得多蠢。
永远不要向那些不爱你的人去证明你对他们有多好，
要证明的是我有多强大，
我有多牛逼，
我有多绝情，
我不需要向你们证明我混的有多好，
我只是告诉你们，
我很自由，
谁也别来绑架我，
谁也别来跟我沾亲带故的，
你们不配，
我的户口本是跟堂哥他们一家不重要，
现在干什么还要户口本？
结婚都不用户口本了有什么关系？
你只要有个身份证，
你上哪工作是不是都身份证就够了，
你将来结婚你身份证就够了。
户口本不行的话去挂失，
户口本不行的话，
你现在在哪个城市？
问在这个城市我要交多少年的社保，
我的户口能转过来集取户给我单开一页，
我现在也是想把户口弄出来，
我甚至也想过，
就是再也不联系，
不是，
甚至有想过就该这么做，
那一堆人，
他们觉得你是否有良心，
他们觉得你是否对有回报重要吗？
你跟他们以后老死不相往来，
坦率的说吧，
我再讲的透彻一点，
姑娘，
你死外面了，
有人真正在意吗？
他们都不在意，
你为什么要在意他们怎么看你，
你为什么要在意他们怎么说你，
你在外面呢？
他们也不会真正的在意和伤心的，
我为什么要在意，
你们怎么评价我，
我脑子是不是有泡，
我现在伤心的是已经3年了，
没有一个人给我发一条信息，
打一个电话，
那就。
好事，
那些人分险你知道吗？
逢年过节，
特别是这种中秋啊，
什么节个起听好了啊，
你现在是一个成年人，
你快30岁了，
把你身上的所有的细胞雷达都给我打开，
去识别哪些人是善良的，
去别哪些人是真心待你的，
就像你在医院门口哭，
会有一个洗盘子洗碗的大姐会给你50块钱，
这样的人她就是善良的人。
本来我在这个世界上就没有血缘关系，
本来他们就是我的养父养母，
对不对？
对养母说，
如果你真的要看病，
你就自己找你亲生父母，
他就给我讲了一个大概的这个地，
他不用找了，
我想不要找了，
因为那个年代他有可能是被迫生下了我，
他如果真的找了也没有意义，
我也不想找他。
你现在需要做的是在这个人世间去识别和链接那些，
他跟你可能就有这个缘分，
就像那个给你50块钱的那个大姐，
她跟你可能就是有这生命链接的缘分，
你需要做的去识别那些善良的人，
跟这些善良的人去建立这个生命的链接。
血缘这个东西，
她在我看来啊，
因为我确实见过太多那种一奶同胞杀的，
杀生杀死的，
打官司打生打死的，
争遗产的，
我也见过那种亲生妈妈对孩子下手特别狠的，
我也见过那种亲生父亲对自己的亲生女儿下手的，
所以我觉得血缘这个东西真的没有那么重要，
重要的是。
识别那些跟你有缘分的善良的人，
真心的看到你难过会伤心，
看到你有困难会想着在能力范围之内给你拉把手的这些人不明白，
那我就是不委去，
再也不要回去，
可以拉黑所有人，
拉开所有以前所谓的亲人相亲都可以拉黑你就当以前的那个自己死掉了，
现在的此刻的你是一个全新的自己，
是一个重新活一遍的自己。
你明白了没？
分析想再问一个，
因为我之前谈了男朋友，
我没有钱了，
要到我男朋友那里去了，
后来就分了。
后来我谈了第二个的时候呢，
他想跟我结婚在一起，
他说要不要见父母，
我因为这个事情跟他分了，
我怕他知道我的原生家庭好简单，
死绝了，
我父母早就死了，
我在世间没有亲人了，
那这样会不会以后结婚欺负我没有亲人，
那就所有的东西都要建立在自己足够狠的基础之上，
有的东西我跟你说都是硬币的两面，
你知道吗？
硬币的两面是什么意思吗？
就像古时候啊，
假设我是宫里的一个宫女儿，
我没有亲人，
我没有九族，
这既是我的弱点，
也是我的优点，
她是我的弱点，
别人看着可能我背后没有九族了啊，
没有人保护我了，
别人可能会欺负我，
但同时的话，
我谁也不怕你谁欺负我，
我告诉你，
我背后没有九族，
我不怕你们灭我九族，
理解了吧，
所有的东西都是硬币的。
层面，
他看到你没有父母，
那同时我也没有牵绊，
你要欺负我的话，
我干死你，
我也不怕连累谁，
就跟叶兰漪似的，
叶兰一背后没有亲人，
谁敢欺负我？
事实啊，
我没有九族，
我不怕，
我基本上是没上学吧，
因为我小学六年级就出来工作，
我基本上是以用什么学历，
我在想要不要弄一个那种成人什么那种升学历吧，
如果说你有这样的时间，
有这样的精历，
有这样的钱，
你可以去搞一个，
但我觉得最关键的是世事洞明皆学问，
人情练达记文章。
就是像那些比你优秀的人身上去学怎么为人处事，
怎么待人接物，
怎么维系关系，
就像那些影视作品里面的主角去学习善良，
学习公平，
学习义气，
学习两口子怎么相处，
就像那些优秀的女性去学习怎么爱别人，
像爱你的人模仿爱你的人的动作，
去学怎么爱别人，
这个东西更重要，
那你分姐，
我现在可以通过什么方式把我的户口录出来，
比如说现在啊，
好多大城市都在抢人，
好多小地方也在抢人，
好多地方你去了解政策是你在这里交社保，
比如说交了一个月好，
你就可以在这个地方要办什么居住证好，
有了居住证就可以在这个地方就背落集体户，
那我明白了，
那我对这些其实我是没有任何概念，
不集体户，
我现在的户口就是集体户，
我觉得跟你说话我心里也舒服，
因为我腾是为什。
朋友吧，
可能他们也跟我借钱借怕了，
我身边没什么人说说话，
我跟你说啊，
借钱这事儿必须有借有还，
我跟你说小话，
我问小借钱看病，
我借了他1万，
我还了一万三百多，
我只要借别人的钱，
我都会多还一点，
一百两百就我能力范围之内，
我只在想，
如果我真的不回去，
那万一以后有什么事情会不会有影响，
没有什么影响。
其实我觉得是这样的，
那些曾经在你需要治病的时候愿意借钱给你的人，
还是要维系关系的，
就是人家释放的善良，
逢年过节还是要给人发个红包呀，
祝福一下，
感谢一下的是不是？
但你没必要说非得见面，
我只要逢年过节的时候我惦记你，
我给你发红包，
我给你问一下，
其实我心里能对得起我自己了，
就养母在养父走后一年出去工作，
他对村里人，
对村里人说是给我去挣钱，
所以以说给我存嫁妆钱，
但其实他是跟了另一个人，
都跟你说了，
永远不要去向一些不在乎你的人去证明一些什么，
不在乎你的人，
就算你做到了42孝，
他照样不在乎你是吧？
他照样看不上你，
他照样觉得你做的不够多。
我为什么要向那个不爱我的人去证明我对他有多好呢？
那些村里面那些人，
他们爱你吗？
我说实话嘛的位姐他们对我还挺好的，
有时候还挺护着我的，
我是说被俺父母打了，
他们还去帮忙拉架，
那你就逢年过节给人发个红包就可以了啊，
其实点被说开我心里。
舒服，
因为我这些天一直睡不着觉，
正在想这个事情啊，
永远不要像那个不爱你的人去证明一些什么，
再说的透彻一点啊，
就算所有的人都骂我没良心，
那又怎样呢？
又能怎样呢？
影响我吗？
不下，
我现在是真的是赵心态啊，
就算所有的人骂我没有良心，
那我不孝，
那我是个无情的薄情寡义的人，
又能怎样呢？
那以后也没有任何法律的纠纷嘛，
也不会产生的，
如果说他有亲生的儿女，
他以后假设揭不开锅了，
他想要打官司，
要儿女给赡养费的话，
那你该给多少给多少？
举个例子，
一个月800的赡养费，
你加上他亲生的儿女，
一人平均下来的话，
可能200块钱300块钱，
那给就是了呗，
那以后如果说养母走了，
我要回去吗？
那不需要，
你永远记住，
就算全世界的人都骂我绝情又能怎样？
就算全世界的人都骂我薄情寡义，
又能怎样？
我心里有一杆秤，
谁对我好我不傻，
我知道是对我好的人，
我要对他好，
帮助过我的人，
我要回馈，
我要感恩，
对我不好的人，
死绝了跟我有什么关系？
明白了，
谢谢谢，
好，
我想说我也挺喜欢你的，
因为我一也，
我一直听你直播，
我还蛮喜欢的，
好嗯嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
对不起啊，
我今天可能情绪也没有控制好，
就说脏话，
说的有点这。
不中听，
但是我很生气，
你看他为什么会被亲生的爹妈放弃，
大概率下，
因为她是一个小姑娘，
谁放弃了这女孩儿的一生，
养到14岁就出去打工了。
14岁是什么概念？
你现在看看你的儿子，
看看你的女儿，
你就知道14岁是什么概念，
他还是个孩子，
他都不知道怎么保护自己，
他要是被欺负了，
他都不知道该找谁，
14岁就出去打工了。
我心里很生气，
我对那些重男轻女的人有愤恨，
我那天还看到一个电影的切片，
就是一个爷爷，
他儿子生了一个女儿，
那个年代的政策就是独生子女的政策，
除非说你生的老大是有残疾，
他听到人家这么说的话，
他就起心动念，
就想把他的女儿给弄成哑巴，
弄成什么残疾，
我也不知道是什么电影，
我就看了这个切片，
一下子就勾起了我控制不住的那种愤怒，
啊，
你14岁出去打工。
我又想起了平凡的世界里面有一个小姑娘，
也是十几岁了就去工地里面做饭啊什么的，
被包工头饭了都不敢声张，
怕不给她在这儿做饭了，
不给他在这儿打工了，
怕回去挨他爸揍。
孙少平给车费路费，
让这个十几岁的小姑娘不要再遭受包工头的委屈和强送他回老家了。
关键是过了一段时间了之后，
又看到他又来了，
为什么呢？
家里人打他，
就非得让他出去挣钱。
平凡的世界里面的这样一个桥段嘛，
我一听到这个姑娘说她14岁就出去打工了，
在我的脑海里面就会浮现出来。
各种各样的猥琐的欺凌欺负，
他的那些可能性就在我的脑海里面就会浮现出来，
我心中就会1万头羊驼在奔腾。
记得点赞关注哦。